[Music]
[Applause]
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and it is a gorgeous day outside and
I've got just a few minutes before I go
meet a friend for a concert so I thought
I would show you a few things about how
to dance with windmills but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyroa
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- buus Friends of the
channel machinski and Becca beckin thank
you both so much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so I got
to say I've always loved po windmills
when it comes to dance one of the
biggest reasons being they're usually
the first poy trick that we learn that
really Force us to do a lot of level
changes that is going from a place that
is around our hips to a place that's up
around our ears or shoulders as such I
think that there's a lot of expressive
capabilities that they have but because
they're in Split time same direction it
can sometimes be a little confusing to
know where to go with them they've got a
big stage setup just over there and
there's a lot of sand blade but
hopefully uh the sound will work for
this everybody knock on wood right all
right so let's start high and then work
our way around shall we now one of those
things that I really like coming out of
a high windmill is to do like a little
stall and switch directions this of
course can be a great thing to do on a
beat and you can also put it together
with reaching with your body like so or
boom adding some leg work into it to
really really make those stalls Pop
Let's see that with music
[Music]
now this next one's a lot trickier but
it's kind of a similar idea you can use
those windmills and do a little bit of a
pendulum you basically just like keep
the hand that's at the back uh hanging
out behind the head and the one that's
in front gets to do a couple pendulums
back and forth before jumping back into
the normal windmill yeah how about that
with music
[Music]
now the good news is that doing stuff up
high makes it really broadcast the bad
news is is that you're working in kind
of a restricted space in that you're
keeping your hands fairly close to your
ears and you don't have a lot of
Mobility up here so of course the next
thing that we can play around with is
adding a little bit of volume to things
and without a doubt one of my favorite
tricks for working with windmills and
dance is to use dropping into uh
extensions or perian man here into a
thing in and of itself you can use boom
that moment to drop the beat and have a
little Dynamic shift that really makes
the music pop yeah let's check that out
with music
[Music]
now I of course was doing a little bit
of a paa with that there's another thing
I like doing with these and that is to
add under curves and over curves to p
truvian man so you take it all the way
around the way this works mechanically
is that I start with like kind of this
tripod pose right here I bend my right
knee then I bend my left knee I
straighten out my left knee and I come
back high yeah so bend right Bend both
straight and right straight and left
like that and as you take that curve
around you can then reflect that in the
work you're doing with the POI in that
PO truvian man kind of place
yeah and of course if we're going to go
big then why not take that all the way
around into a herette like so you can
use that moment when you drop into the
behind the head part of the windmill as
a beat to kind of stabilize yourself
before taking yourself all the way back
around with those extensions in the
bottom part of the p truvian man yeah
cool so now let's see all of those
different pieces in action
[Music]
yeah me with goodbye were goodbye I'm
better on the all
side cuz I burning up on you burning up
on you you that
you
with I'm better on the other side I'm
better on the other
[Music]
side sweet deal so those are some ideas
for what you can do to dance with your
windmills which one was your favorite
and did I miss any let me know down in
the comments and uh make sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find this video and to help
my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without the kind support of all these
nice people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently a patreon uh
subscriber and you would like to become
one you can do that by heading on over
to
patreon.com factor Po and signing up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and you'll be helping
me out in my mission to bring boy
spinning and flow Arts to The Wider
world do check that out please and thank
you and as for me I have to haul my butt
over to the Kennedy Center right now to
make this concert I'm looking forward to
it thanks for chilling with me here and
uh be on the lookout for more of these
videos on how to dance with different po
moves coming up uh if you dug this video
I will leave a link to a playlist of
other videos like it down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well thanks for watching have a good
one and I'll see you with a new video
very soon peace